the feud between Tyrese Gibson and
Dwayne the rock Johnson continues when
Johnson who plays Luke Hobbs in the
action-packed Fast & Furious film series
announced that he would be starring in
his own spin-off movie Hobson Shaw
Gibson known for playing the
fast-talking former convict Roman Pearce
began viewing his franchise co-star as
something of an enemy tension between
the two has been high for years now but
in the days following the August 2nd
launch of Hobbes and Shaw things have
reached a boiling over point hey Mia you
better hide your baby oil I'm just
playing you better hide that big-ass
forehead this joke Gibson recently took
to Instagram to slam Johnson for his
decision to film Hobbes and Shaw before
the 9th Fast & Furious movie poke fun at
Hobson Chows 180 million worldwide
opening weekend and hit that Johnson and
his co-star Jason Statham will
experience continued backlash from
others
Gibson also seemed to imply that the
only reason why Johnson is a favorite in
Hollywood is because he has been part of
quote at least 15 franchises and has
continually asked to star in sequels
Gibson wrote in a now-deleted post in
part I have to show my respects for one
thing he tried folks called me a hater
attacked me for speaking out breaking up
the family clearly doesn't have the
value that one would assume it does you
know what maybe just maybe the rock and
the crew will come dance with us again
for fast 10 we can all hug it out and
get back to giving the true fans who
have supported this franchise for 20
years what they want know Haiti I'm just
pointing out the facts fast family has
more value as the fast family it's okay
there won't be any tears on his pillow
tonight 180 million dollar global
opening on Hobson Shaw is not a win when
you do get attacked well that's that
again my respects cuz he tried his best
this is just the latest shot fired in
the Gibson versus Johnson battle Gibson
has been publicly unhappy with Johnson
since news of the Hobbs and Shaw
spin-off hit in 2017 in Gibson's defense
Hobbes and Shaw did complicate the
production of Fast and Furious 9
longtime screenwriter Chris Morgan left
the project to work on Hobson Shaw and
despite Gibson's pleas to Johnson to
prioritize fast and furious 9 over the
spin-off flick the movie was pushed back
Fast and Furious 9 was ultimately
delayed nearly a year
moving from its planned April 19th 2019
release date to April 10th 2020 the
premiere date change was seemingly what
sent Gibson over the edge in another
post on his Instagram page uploaded in
October 2017
Gibson wrote a scathing message openly
blaming Johnson for delaying fast and
furious 9 congratulations to the rock
and your brother-in-law aka seven bucks
producing partner Hyrum Garcia for
making the Fast and Furious franchise
about you and like you DJ even if they
call I will not be deleting this post
good night folks
see you in 2020 April fast family right
now it's about team Dwayne and the actor
previously called Johnson out over Hobbs
and Shaw and Instagram writing if you
move forward with that Hobbs movie you
will have purposely ignored the
heart-to-heart moment we had in my
Sprinter I don't want to hear from you
until you remember what we talked about
I'm on your timeline cuz you're not
responding to my text messages fast
family is just that a family we don't
fly solo and in November 2017
Gibson threatened to quit the Fast and
Furious franchise if Johnson got to be
in bolt Hobson Shaw and past nine he
wrote on Instagram I'm sorry to announce
that if Dwayne is in Fast 9 there will
be no more Roman Pearce he went on to
call Johnson a clown and worse
ultimately accusing him of using
steroids to obtain his ultra ripped
physique and applying that Johnson's
professional decisions have quotes
messed with his family Gibson explained
in a separate post that he was primarily
mad at Johnson for agreeing to the
spin-off film without considering how it
might affect Gibson's own life finances
and personal struggles which at the time
included paying for unidentified legal
fees and apparently fighting for custody
of his daughter
Gibson wrote all I asked you to do
privately was not accept a role that
would deeply affect us all you are
simply not the People's Champ you are a
selfish champ I'm almost broke swimming
in legal fees
make sure you kiss your two daughters
when you get home I wish I could but I
can't afford to fight for my baby
anymore so they're likely going to take
her away just a few days after sharing
those posts to Instagram Gibson again
took to a social media platform of
choice the state Betty had smooth things
over with one of Johnson's associates
and was excited to return for fast and
furious 9 since veteran franchise
director just
Linn was confirmed to be at the health
he also said it would be his last post
about Johnson which Ralph didn't exactly
pan out this fiasco could be the final
battle in the war between Gibson and
Johnson as Johnson won't be involved
with fast and furious 9 whether or not
Gibson can let bygones be bygones
remains to be seen but it looks like the
era of Gibson and Johnson sharing the
screen together and the fast ranch eyes
might be coming to a screeching halt
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stars are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]